you do ads for Jim Beam I did I see
those ads a lot and they're cool-looking
ads what I'm what I'm curious about is I
know that you there are some celebrities
they come to you and they say do you
want to do this product but you actually
had it your own interest in doing an ad
yeah Jim Beam what was that all those
like a little bit of a joint venture I I
noticed I used to drink vodka and I
drank a drink called the penicillin
which is a Scotch based beverage and I
was like oh my gosh I really love scotch
and whiskey and rye and bourbon mm-hmm
and as I started looking more into the
spirit world I realized they weren't
very many females that were in the brown
liquor industry like there was some like
people doing a little bit of vodka and a
little bit of tequila but there was
nobody advertising and or producing
their own bourbon scotch whiskey right
and so I was like you know what I'm
gonna go and look around and snoop
around and I want to see if I can buy a
distillery and how does this world work
and and through different channels
I was joint with Jim Beam in a in a
joint effort to like you know one day
hopefully have a you know a label of my
own and learn a lot it looks something
like that you've gotten out of the
t-shirt business you want to legally
this is this is actual yeah this is a
real do you drink do you a bourbon I'm
not I don't really do spirits I'm not a
hard liquor drinker I like me some wine
I like some wine it's you but I don't I
don't often but I'm always curious
because would you want to try one yeah
do you drink yes
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you brought I bring this out cuz you
brought this and I thought back here and
I thought okay he's gonna come out at
some point the best way to do that you
referred to the liquor business as the
spirit world
yeah very Mysterio hold on we're about
to enter the spirit world so Mila what
is it we're having here what is it the
it's just regular Jim Beam Andy's gonna
need more a little bit of bourbon yes
fine I could wait the commercial you
have to wait can I say yes I don't know
anything I have to say I'm one of those
people that occasionally I get a drink
with an umbrella in it but I'm not
sophisticated in the ways of my spirits
what do I do
so this is what I was taught to drink
this properly like unlike wine where you
breathe it in from the nose you keep
your mouth open in order to let some of
the fumes out so you first breathe it
with your mouth open like okay breathe
it in mouth open I just look like a
[ __ ] that's the problem take a sip and
then you're gonna chew it chew chew a
liquid I'll show you ready you got like
this right now taught me this
that's a chipmunk chew that's not a real
it's all we came out I think I'm doing
it it's just like I'm a ventriloquist
it's just coming out of my mouth this is
why I don't get Jim Beam offers anymore
we're sorry about Conan he's a complete
idiot
you